- All right, we're going in here.
- Oh! Hello.
- Hello.
- Hello, how are you today?
- Good. How are you?
- Nice to meet you.
- Hi, nice to meet you, I'm Jerry.
I like tarot cards. Do
you like tarot cards?
- Yeah, alright. Let's see tarot cards.
You like getting a little tired?
(laughing)
Can't hold the camera like you used to.
It's like, "Yeah I'll take the job.
"But can I sit down?"
(laughing)
- Ah. This is looking good.
- You're strong-minded.
When you set your mind to something
you have to follow it out.
- Yes.
- You analyze people
that are surrounding you.
(cameraman laughing)
(cellphone ringing)
- Is that yours?
- [Cameraman] I don't think it's me.
- [Jerry] It's not me.
(laughing)
- It's that spirit calling me.
- They really are aggressive
these days, aren't they?
- (laughing) Oh my!
- They used to do it like, psychically.
Now they just call.